Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Continuing
in the 12th book of the book of
knowledge
discussing the hadith hadith number 1386
of
it's the narration of musi it's a
well-known narration amongst the
scholars and students of Islam
And it really gives us an insight
into
the reaction that people have when they
receive the knowledge, the revelation of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala as a
prerequisite
or we could say a prelude to
this topic.
When you read in the Quran, Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala giving an analogy
of rain that falls upon
a piece of land and that land then
brings forth its fruits and vegetation
and trees and or or holds the water so
that the water can be utilized by other
creatures on the earth.
This is simultaneously always an analogy
for the revelation of Allah subhanahu wa
tala.
Think about it. Think about the effects
that revelation has.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala sends down
rain and it nourishes us. We have all
grown from the earth. All of us. We have
all been nourished by the earth and the
earth has been nourished by the heavens.
And that's the connection. Allah sends
down the rain and based on what the
earth contains in itself, it brings
forth the best that that land has to
offer. What brings forth the best that
that land has to offer? The rain.
Likewise, when Allah sends down verses
of the Quran, when he sends down
revelation, not just the Quran, but all
revelations from Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala, it has the same effect
on the human heart and the human spirit
as that rain has on the earth.
So the phys physical effect of rain on
the ground is the same effect that
revelation has on the spirit of man.
And so every one of us right now we were
just listening to the Quran. All of us
just now simultaneously received
in this junction in our lives at this
moment at this time under these
circumstances we have just listened to
words of almighty Allah our creator. Now
how did we react to those words? What is
the reaction? What do we take home?
Did they change us? Did they have an
effect on us? If they did not, why did
they not have an effect?
And this is the analogy that is
mentioned here in this narration. This
is why it's such a well-known narration.
Abu Mus who is one of the scholars of
the companions.
He tells us that the prophet Sam
said
for.
[Silence]
So he mentions in this analogy
three types of land.
Three types of recipients
of the Quran and Sunnah. Three types of
land that receive this rain this
rainfall.
He says the parable the analogy of that
which Allah has sent me with of guidance
and knowledge. Notice here the words
guidance and knowledge meaning Quran and
Sunnah. The essence of revelation, the
essence of intellect. This is
[Silence]
So knowledge the essence of thought
true sound logic
in its two in its two forms
which are deduction and induction.
ction,
deductive reasoning and inductive
reasoning. That's the essence of logic,
right? The mind. And then we have the
guidance of the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam. And then we have the verses of
the Quran.
Those are the three.
We see as well
that
from another aspect
that everything in the Quran is one of
these two categories. It's either
guidance or knowledge. Guidance is what
you implement. The laws of the Quran and
Sunnah, the laws of Allah, right? The
dos and don'ts, what we can put into
action. That's al and is the knowledge
that Allah gives us that doesn't
directly
is not directly put into action. The
names and attributes of Allah the
history of the of Allah the history of
the enemies of Allah the history of the
earth the history of creation of man.
So he says the analogy
of that which Allah has sent me with of
guidance and knowledge is a strong
rain which came down upon a piece of of
the ground, a piece of land.
And so part of this land was a very pure
and good and rich land
which in turn
was grown and cultivated and pushed
forth its grass and fruits and
vegetation
as a result of this rain. So it took the
rain and it gave back
food, nourishment. It took the rain,
received it, and then it pushed back and
gave back what? As a result, vegetation,
trees, fruits, vegetables, all of these
things.
He says,
"And another part of this land was
in itself pure but stiff.
And so it was able to gather the rain
and hold the water. So it didn't
necessarily produce anything with the
rain, but it kept the rain together and
pure.
And so people were able to benefit from
these aadib
which is a land that is shaped in a
particular way. It is pure and it will
hold the rain and from it we have lakes,
we have rivers, we have large bodies of
water which people and animals are able
to what go to and become nourished.
So those are two types of people. The
scholars tell us this is an analogy of
the and the of Islam.
The fukah they receive the rain. They
understand it and they bring forth
something that people can
use directly.
Those are the scholars of f those who
give us the results.
And then we have the muadin
who
are
commissioned
to hold the rain so that others can use
it. They don't necessarily process the
rain themselves. They hold it pure all
in one place. So you can go and use that
rain so other creatures can benefit from
that rain. So we have one type of person
who's able to understand
and influence others and we have another
person who is able to learn and pass on
the knowledge to others even if they
themselves are not as able to bring
forth the minutia and the details of
that knowledge. But then there's a third
type. There's a third type of person. He
says,
[Silence]
Rain came down upon a type that neither
benefits others by holding the water nor
does it
produce any kind of vegetation
to nourish others.
When the water hits it, it just rolls
right off of it. No good comes from this
land. Not even any not even some grass.
So that you know it it it helps to form
a pasture. It's a dead land. No matter
how much water comes down on it, it will
either just suck the water down in and
produce nothing or the water will just
roll right off of it because of its
shape.
Zero benefit to the rest. It's like
trying to teach a black hole.
Or it's trying to satisfy
an entitled person. How can you ever
satisfy someone who's entitled?
Impossible. How can you ever compliment
someone who's insecure? Impossible. How
can you ever teach a black hole?
Impossible. All it does is consume.
And so he says,
[Silence]
So these are the examples the analogy of
a person who understood
what Allah communicated in his
revelation
And Allah benefited this person and used
him to learn and teach his revelations.
And that is also the analogy
of those who neither
use the knowledge in order to better and
become a source of pride nor did they
hold the knowledge for others to come
and benefit from it. It just swallowed
the water or it just rolled right off of
it. So you have to ask yourself, these
are three types of people. Those who
understand,
those who memorize, and those who
neither understand nor memorize.
They're too busy. Their schedule's too,
you know, locked. They can't they just
don't have the time. They have no
drive.
And so no matter how much of the Quran
they hear, it won't change anything. No
matter how much of the sunnah they hear,
it won't change anything. Why? Because
of either the shape of the ground,
which means that when they hear the
Quran, they have already put themselves
in a position to close their heart,
right? It's closed. or they will take it
and not yield anything.
Why? Because of a disease that's inside
of the heart.
This is why Allah says
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us that
a person in order to benefit from the
Quran, to benefit from the Sunnah, your
heart has to be open even a little bit.
And this is speaking about the believers
and disbelievers. No Muslim,
no Muslim, true Muslim who has the
pillars of faith and the pillars of
Islam intact
will completely be useless
and untouched and unchanged by the Quran
and Sunnah. This Muslim does not exist.
There has to be some good in there
somewhere. Even if it is the weight of a
mustard seed. And this is why in the day
of judgment, Allah will tell the
believers, "Go into the fire and take
out anyone who has in his heart a grain
weight of emen.
Go back into the fire and take out
anyone who has in his heart a
mustard seeds weight in ean. Go back
into the fire and take out anyone who
has in his heart even a tiny ant's
weight of eman.
Because every believer Muslim who has
the pillars of Islam, the pillars of
iman, they are one of these two types of
people in some way.
However, the disbeliever no matter how
much of the Quran and Sunnah they hear
[Arabic recitation]
Just a reminder, we have QR codes around
the masid on the wall. If you're not
part of the WhatsApp group, please zap
it with your phone, add yourself to the
WhatsApp group so you can get all of the
announcements and the videos and so
forth. These videos, they do as well go
up on Facebook
if you're still living in 2007 or
YouTube. I believe that's the only
platforms